[Música]
bienvenidos a este espacio para hablar
de medio ambiente aquí en france24 yo
soy maría clara calle y hoy analizaremos
la difícil situación energética que
enfrenta la unión europea y es que en
medio de la guerra en ucrania el bloque
no ha prohibido las importaciones de gas
y petróleo de rusia como sí lo hicieron
eeuu y canadá la razón es que la energía
de las 27 naciones europeas depende en
gran medida de rusia este país exportó
cerca del 45 por ciento del gas que se
consumió en toda la unión europea en
2021 casi una tercera parte del petróleo
que se consume en el bloque es ruso y un
46 por ciento del carbón provino del
mismo país esto hace que rusia sea de
lejos el mayor suministro energético de
la unión europea y no es un dato menor
pues más del 90 por ciento del gas y del
petróleo que se consume en el bloque es
importado por eso la pregunta que se
hace todos es cómo reducir la
dependencia de rusia la agencia
internacional de energía publicó un
documento con diez ideas dentro de ellas
no incluyo aumentar la producción de
carbón porque incrementaría las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
pero reconoció que sería una de las
opciones más rápidas para reemplazar al
gas ruso y ahí está el dilema de la
unión europea porque más combustibles
fósiles los alejaría del pacto verde
europeo o el green deal con el que
pretenden ser el primer continente
climáticamente neutro para 2050 desde
copenhague alexandre y el director del
programa de energía global nissan gap
nos explicó que podría pasar
con el euro a corto plazo tenemos el
riesgo de aumentar nuestro consumo de
carbón en europa para lidiar
especialmente con las necesidades
inmediatas del invierno que vienen a we
see that
vemos eso principalmente en república
checa bulgaria italia y alemania- pero
es importante resaltar que las
decisiones a corto plazo todavía están
en el aire
es crucial que las decisiones no
prolonguen la vida de los combustibles
fósiles incluido el carbón pero también
el petróleo y el gas
yo creo que lo que está pasando es
consecuencia del nerviosismo sobre cómo
desvincular las estructuras energéticas
europeas de rusia y eso lleva el temor
por el invierno
todos intentan prepararse para octubre
parece importante recordar que el
invierno que viene es cuando europa será
más vulnerable a rusia entonces es
fundamental que las decisiones que se
tomen ya no sean para muchos años
wright
[Música]
ahí es donde está el debate por wisin
puede que necesitemos carbón para los
próximos 12 meses pero más allá de eso
no hay necesidad de revivir una
industria de combustibles fósiles que
europa ya dejó atrás your power in
boston de penas ante este panorama la
comisión europea propuso a principios de
marzo una estrategia a la que llamó ry
power y con la que espera terminar la
dependencia de los combustibles rusos de
aquí al 2030 su aspiración es reducir
dos tercios de las importaciones rusas
en un solo año
para lograrlo del plan ripa where you
tiene dos pilares primero es
diversificar las fuentes de gas
importando más de otros países como eeuu
o noruega y también aumentando la
producción energética del bio metano y
del hidrógeno renovable el segundo
fundamento es que consuman menos
combustibles fósiles y apuesten más por
la eficiencia energética y las energías
renovables alexander y el coinciden que
la salida más segura para lograr la
independencia es apostarle a las
energías limpias
rangers eres ha demostrado cuán
peligroso es para europa depender de los
combustibles fósiles de rusia pero
también de otros regímenes autoritarios
la volatilidad del precio que vemos en
el gas y el petróleo que se vivió antes
de la crisis en ucrania pero que se
exacerbó con los ataques rusos será la
nueva normalidad para los combustibles
fósiles
si queremos estabilidad del precio
seguridad y prevenir el cambio climático
entonces las energías renovables y la
eficiencia energética son la mejor
manera de lograrlo
mattingly cyber member es importante
recordar que el gas ya sea ruso o gas
natural licuado de eeuu es una fuente
principal de metano que es un gas de
efecto invernadero 80 veces más potente
que el co2 por eso reducir el promedio
de consumo de un gas de europa es una de
las mejores inversiones que podemos
hacer para prevenir el cambio climático
y para la independencia energética
ante esto la unión europea piensa en las
soluciones del bio metano y el hidrógeno
renovable el primero es el gas que se
obtiene de la degradación
y dos orgánicos mientras que el
hidrógeno renovable se puede producir de
diferentes maneras como separando la
molécula del hidrógeno del agua mediante
la energía solar o el gas combustible y
esa es una de las advertencias que hace
alexander y en él nos explicó que tanta
energía producen esas dos fuentes y cuál
es su riesgo
ahora es una parte relativamente
insignificante de la producción
energética de la unión europea
tenemos que ser cuidadosos no sólo el
tamaño que puede ocupar sino también
entender que es algo que no ocurrirá
mañana
ni fein andy no es algo que podamos
prender y ya tener biometano e hidrógeno
renovable esto
todavía falta muchos años y hay sobre
estimaciones de cuánto podemos producir
además recordemos que el hidrógeno
renovable está hecho de energía
renovable pero también puede hacerse con
gas combustible
cuando creemos una infraestructura de
metano es importante que eso no se
convierta en una infraestructura fósil
tiene que estar ligada a la energía
renovable y winter's ser
e insisto en que lo mejor que podemos
hacer es aumentar drásticamente el
despliegue de energía renovable
combinado con la eficiencia energética y
así llegamos al final de nuestro
programa pueden ver esta y otras
emisiones en france24 punto com nos
vemos
[Música]